Hyderabad India's fourth biggest city is
past becoming one of the most exciting
visitor destinations in the country
Hyderabad these are really really known
for their hospitality its booming tech
scene is attracting global attention
it's more like wine when you start
enjoying it you really what in love with
it and transforming this ancient city
into a cosmopolitan hotspot it's an
amazing time to be invaded at once home
to the richest man in the world and the
center of the global diamond trade
Hyderabad is full of hidden gems you
just have to know where to find them
three passionate locals are about to
take you on a tour of their city
revealing the secret spots where you can
experience the real Hyderabad
if you want to capture the vibrancy
color and sounds of Hyderabad you'll
need to get up early just like the
flower merchants of goodie multiple
flower market
[Music]
as flowers are an integral part of
Indian life this market attracts buyers
and sellers from across the region
it's also a favorite spot for keen
photographers
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is solid Chatterjee I'm a travel
photographer
[Music]
inside wood I had a dream to travel and
take pictures for the people who can't
travel syrup has taken his love of
photography one step further and now
shares it with visitors by running photo
walks I like bringing people to the
flower market because there's so much
happening there it's all about the color
of the flowers the texture of the
flowers also looking for details and
being more aware of what is around
wonderful luck there Victor it's very
interesting to watch these people and
interact with them and then you take a
picture by joining sourabh it's a chance
to see this city and its people through
a very different lens I have to capture
one particular moment to freeze that
moment market stall holders here aren't
just selling flowers they're also
creating garlands for every type of
celebration in this city for the use of
garland in weddings is just like in the
West you have exchanging rings so this
is where the husband and wife becomes
one each and every garland is made by
hand an art form that's perfected over
years
because at one hour saw reps photos have
taken him all over India one frame at a
time but it's Hyderabad's people and
iconic locations that inspire him the
most
my name's Steve a Scarborough and the
CEO of tea hub which is India's fastest
growing startup engine
I'd love to welcome you all to cyber bud
so called cyber bad is the home to
Hyderabad's flourishing tech and startup
community the ambition is to create
India's answer to Silicon Valley and
it's fast attracting a young
cosmopolitan crowd in the last few years
there's been an explosion in the number
of clubs bars restaurants because what
we're seeing is hydroid is really
becoming a global city the building to
our left is the building for Google and
they're currently building their largest
campus outside of the amount of you
headquarters here in Hyderabad but when
Srinivas has business visitors he
doesn't take them to the newest parts of
town
he takes them to the oldest the street
markets of Charminar in the old city
have been the beating heart of Hyderabad
for 400 years this was the centre of the
world's diamond and pearl industry
during the time of the Nizam's who ruled
over Hyderabad from 1724 to 1948 near
Hyderabad were the famous Paul Condor
mines which produced some of the largest
diamonds in the world in fact the
Kohinoor that is in the crown jewels of
the UK at the Hope Diamond which was one
the largest blue diamonds in the world
all of these came from the mines near
here what that meant was that this place
was fabulously wealthy and because of
that Hyderabad became a true trading
city the diamond industry may have moved
on but the pearl trade is still alive
and well giving the city its Monica the
city of pearls attracting buyers from
around the world yes sir okay I'm
looking for some pearls okay and what
Sreenivasan gets a kick out of is
schooling his Western visitors in the
age-old art of haggling so how much is
this set is three thousand to fifty
three thousand to fifty yes that's a
little high I would say fifteen hundred
because if the original fall okay and
we'll provide lifetime guarantee
certificate okay so very nice yes but
I'd say fifteen hundred rupees 15 and
what a discount you can
I can do some concession for you okay
I've already spent person for you 2009
20 fights I still think it's too much
I'm sure you can do better than this
I'd say 2,000 rupees Oh sir mm will be
very low so I will do my best I will do
it 20% for you okay okay the first thing
is start low then stand your ground and
be prepared to walk away if you don't
get the right price so this is a good
price
yes sir sir thank you very much but the
best tip of all to grab a bargain get a
local to do the haggling for you and if
haggling doesn't make you feel like a
local then a bone-rattling ride in the
back streets of Begum pet might do the
job
my name is actually Jane theorists coop
Allen but most people called me John
Bates a nickname I got in college and it
established I think I'm a bit of a nomad
I belong to a South Indian family but I
grew up in the northern part of the
country I found this a perfect place for
me since arriving in Hyderabad 13 years
ago John T decided to set up her own
business taking people to the true heart
of the city and a place where most
travelers never get to visit the
authentic Indian kitchen home dining is
becoming very popular with travelers but
here at Isha's they don't just come to
eat but to learn the secrets and skills
of Hyderabadi home cooking and this is
the chilli powder and this is the chili
powder okay and it's not Himalayan salt
okay this is the Himalayan pink salt
yeah okay wow that's a lot of salt
so the food here tends to be a little
more spicy and a little more salty
companion that is in the country I think
you understand how people cook and what
they cook with and it does give you a
glimpse into their life and especially
if you are going to a local home you get
to see how they live and what kind of
life they lead it gets you to under the
skin of the city as well I have a few
friends who come here looking for curry
powder and it makes it very difficult
for me to explain to them that we don't
have something like curry powder in
India it's an invention which the
British did in fact the word curry
itself doesn't really mean what it means
to most Westerner for example in this
part of the country kareem literally
means just a vegetable this is no
five-star restaurant but it offers
visitors an even rarer experience the
opportunity to really see how the locals
do it in India we prefer to eat with our
fingers because we believe that one it
tastes better your closer to the food
secondly when you lick your fingers it
actually activates the digestive juices
so if food also gets digested much
better if you eat with your fingers and
you really cannot eat some of this with
a fork and a knife
don't babies across town
Srinivas has a very different way for
people to get inside the city one of my
favorite places to bring people is the
Taj Falaknuma Palace it's one of the top
palace hotels in the country and it's
just this amazingly luxurious incredible
experience the felucca Lamar Palace
Hotel used to be the royal guest house
for the richest man in the world
Osman Ali Khan the last Nizam ruler
this is where I come for high tea with a
splash of history
a diversion welcome to total acapellas
please come but those in the know t here
comes with a personal tour with the
resident historian this unique palace
took 10 years to build 22 yesterday
correct
the last Nizam of Hyderabad Kingdom was
the richest man in the world in 1937 he
converted this palace into royal guest
house the likes of King jaws Queen Mary
Edward date straight in his palace
this is the longest dining table in the
world of 101 chairs the palace has
played host to many illustrious guests
and these are the comments written by
Ivanka Trump when she had dinner with
the Prime Minister of India that's a
really interesting signature there but
visitors don't need to rely on their
connections to taste the highlife here
just follow the routine of Hyderabad's
former ruler and take high tea on the
palace hotel's terrace
it's one of my favorite places to bring
people it's just such a luxurious
experience to step back in time makes
you feel like royalty in a city of seven
million people sometimes you need to
find a quiet corner for peaceful
contemplation and sourabh knows just the
spot mala ali hill
[Music]
so once I was looking for a place to go
and I found this place on top of a hill
and I thought let me come here and see
how it looks like now so amazed with the
view that I am getting here and I didn't
know how I spent a couple of hours there
and after that I've been coming here
again and again to reflect on myself and
the whole city the people who live here
and and on my life as well at the top of
moula ali Hill is a 16th century firaga
a Muslim shrine the fergus reputed
healing properties turned it into a
pilgrimage site and countless devotees
climb the 500 steps to the top very
interesting life that you see around
when you go to that place people say
that their wishes get fulfilled when
they go there so people come from really
far and irrespective of their religion
[Music]
but praying in Hyderabad isn't all about
quiet contemplation it's a chance to
party too
and with over 50 religious festivals in
the calendar year there's always an
opportunity to get involved every
neighborhood will hold its own
festivities and for jaunty it's the best
way to immerse visitors in the hyderabad
street scene one of the ways we show our
love for visitors is wanting them to be
a part of our festival so there's always
room for another place at the table
there's always room for one more person
at an Indian weddings so if you want to
get into the spirit of those festivals
you just should not hesitate and just
join and we'll be more than happy to
welcome you
[Applause]
it may seem overwhelming but if you want
to properly appreciate these festivals
there's only one thing for it
leap right in I think at last count
Hindus have about 40 million gods
[Music]
the most popular festival amongst the
communities would be the ganesh festival
or the birthday of the elephant god and
it's a time when the whole city comes to
life
[Music]
some of the most popular festivals last
for up to 11 days
today's celebrations culminate with the
watery immersion of the Ganesh idols a
boisterous farewell as he's returned to
his heavenly home
it may be the end of the night for John
T but for Srinivas the night is just
beginning at one of the most fashionable
hangouts in the city there's an amazing
new bar you enter your secret code you
actually have to know someone you have
to know where it is but then you walk in
and is this incredibly opulent beautiful
bar where they actually serve you I had
where the cocktails Srinivas is here to
catch up with his friend Teddy Sweeney
owner and brains behind this pioneering
bar I love this place so I need a drink
aya vada is a form of traditional Indian
holistic medicine with ancient origins
Ayurvedic could be applied to every area
of your life it literally is your food
the way you sleep the way what kind of
exercise suits you so applying it to
something like alcohol which is
traditionally kind of damaging yeah this
is the most beautiful way to sort of
integrate it without the harmful effects
I don't think anybody would ever think
about healthy alcohol drinks I know but
you know what
Ayurveda was one of the first to include
medicinal wines in their repertoire it's
based on the belief that health and
wellness depend on a delicate balance
between the mind audience spirit
depending on your unique body type
except to figure out my body type your
body type will tell you what kind of
alcohol and what kind of mixers to put
into your drink to merlins it and what
all this does is it helps you wake up
fresh without a hangover which is that's
so it tells me that I am half a dominant
see you're a boy you take can handle
hard alcohol really well yeah yes so I
think I'll order a new fashion ooh
that's a good one you should try that
yeah all right
could I get a new fashioned please
and hopefully that means tomorrow
morning I won't have a hangover
and whatever you think about Ayurveda
it's certainly a fun way to choose a
cocktail it's the perfect end to a day
in the city of contrasts where the old
meets new shows where tradition meets
innovation
you